Each team will have five minutes
to pitch, everybody knows that.
They will then have five minutes
for questions and answers
after their pitch.
The 15K Creative
Arts Competition
is for student arts
focused businesses.
So this is an area of
arts entrepreneurship
that tends to mix the
arts and technology
and sciences up in
very interesting ways.
Well, first of all,
I think MIT is just
an incredibly creative place.
There are so many
creative people here.
I remember as a student, just
thinking that, in a sense,
art was everywhere.
As a woman of color and as
a citizen in this earth,
I have some concerns.
The parameter for
applying is really just
to have an idea, even if
you're a solo entrepreneur.
Because after you apply, there
are six weeks of mentoring,
and networking, and workshops,
so that at the end of April,
at Live Pitch Day, you have
a strong business plan,
you've considered
your market, you've
considered your past market,
you considered your team,
your value prop, and
all of the other things
that an important business has.
The mentorship component really
helped us rethink some of our--
the way we're presenting
our ideas, and even
some of our business
model questions.
So that was really helpful.
I think the most important
thing is not the result.
It's the process
during the competition.
We're seeing a lot of
technological disruption
in the arts.
And MIT being a
leader in technology,
it just needs to be
involved in supporting
the arts from a
technological perspective.
[music playing]